klaus barbie devant la cour d'assises du
rhône le procès de l'ancien dirigeant
nazi s'est ouvert aujourd'hui à 13
heures une édition spéciale de ce
journal en direct de lyon ce lundi 11
mai un jour supplémentaire de détention
pour les otages français au liban marcel
fontaine
marcel carton jean paul kauffmann et
jean louis normandin d'antenne 2 n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
bonsoir la première audience du procès
de klaus barbie vient de s'achever il ya
quelques minutes nous sommes dans cette
salle d'assises du rhône salle
spécialement aménagée et si cette
première audience eu conventionnelle
juridiques je dirais elle lui elle connu
un temps fort un moment d'émotion à
l'arrivée de l'accusé klaus barbie il
était un peu plus de 13 heures
13h05 précisément le président andré cyr
dini ouvre l'audience du procès le plus
chargé de symboles de l'histoire l'islam
moderne lou williams et numérique
je demande au service d'autres
n'introduire l'accusé simulait
l'image qui résume tout ce symbole de
ces gars aussi l'arrivée de klaus par
l'office dans le box des accusés
il apparaît calme
sous le regard
l'ensemble de la presse nationale qui
est là et aussi des témoins qui sont
dans la cellule et mifid qui ne les
regardera jamais
klaus barbie
taux longs de danse
et tout de suite ne fixera que des
avocats des parties civiles qui sont
devant lui sont présents tous
les conseils et participe pour l'instant
il parle avec ses interprètes
le président fait l'appel des parties
civiles
vous avez commis
ici vous représentez persistent
parmi les témoins qui observe barbie des
femmes des hommes qui sont passés par
ses mains qu'il a envoyée vers
l'allemagne accompagné
d'un simple bulletin de livraison les
pièces sont d'ailleurs au dossier on les
appelle les quatre grands scellé
klaus barbie première audience
il est de nouveau la vedette
quarante ans après barbie est l'homme
que les lyonnais regarde encore
mais cette fois ils lui demandent
justice et il ne pourra répondre par un
rire
et puis les photographes et les caméras
sont sortis sur la demande du président
s'indigne et paul lefèvre alors là c'est
passé un moment important pour gérer le
déroulement du procès c'est à dire
l'organisation du jury oui je crois que
c'est le moment le plus important parce
que on attendait la composition de ces
gens qui ont finalement jugé barbie et
faire une page y construire une page
d'histoire alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que en plus des trois magistrats
hommes qui sont là et bien certaines un
lien dans les jurés populaires quatre
femmes et cinq hommes moyenne d'âge 39
ans aucun n'était né au moment où barbie
se trouvait à lyon alors on peut citer l
ingénieur un agent commercial de femme
sans profession un comptable un
technicien en somme un profil très
simple de la société française et ses
jurés vont avoir à juger le plus grand
dossier de l'histoire judiciaire alors
paul peut-être certains ont-ils été déçu
car on a surtout avait assisté cet après
midi à une audience de procédure
oui mais là la procédure c'est
finalement le le respect de la loi c'est
à dire aujourd'hui on a beaucoup passer
de temps sur les vérifications des
parties civiles c'est à dire le bien
fondé des plaintes des victimes la
présentation des victimes alors je crois
que ce procès sera parsemé de bataille
de procédure mais l'absence de
procédures l'avenir du respect de la
liberté des autres et des droits des
autres c'est finalement l'arbitraire et
c'est finalement ce qu'on reprochait à
l'idéologie que représente aujourd'hui
barbie moi je crois que la procédure
même dans ses excès ses c'est la
démocratie et il y aura beaucoup de
procédures pendant deux mois voilà pour
ce qu'on peut dire dans les premières
heures de cette audience de ce qui se
passait à l'intérieur du palais de
justice de lyon à l'extérieur gérard
beaufils et jean-françois chevet
observer les réactions
extrait de la prison saint joseph où il
séjourne maintenant depuis quatre ans
klaus barbie arrive 12h10 très
précisément fondant cellulaire et sous
bonne escorte au palais de justice
jusqu'au dernier moment du dîner rers
avait été gardé secret l'éventualité
d'une tentative d'attentât n'ayant pas
été écartée le dispositif de sécurité en
conséquence avait même été renforcé
la fourgonnette de police amène le
criminel de guerre nazi jusque dans la
cour du dépôt puis par be est ensuite
conduit menottes aux poignets dans une
cellule de repos proche de la cour
d'assises où un médecin et son avocat
vont pouvoir lui rendre visite
partout jusque sur les toits les tireurs
d'élite veille le procès va bientôt
pouvoir débuter sous haute surveillance
à l'extérieur quelques manifestants
s'étaient rassemblés pour déposer des
gerbes de fleurs en hommage aux victimes
du génocide
et puis ce matin en présence de raymond
barre et de nombreuses personnalités le
monument du souvenir avait été inaugurée
en plein coeur de la ville
les mères des enfants juifs d'être un
grand jour parce qu'enfin niveau sa mère
au moment du crime préparer et barbie
noire même si longtemps après payer pour
ses crimes et a jugé certains n'ont pas
oublié d'autres tout près du palais se
désintéresse de ce moment d'histoire qui
se déroule pourtant à leur portée
ça vous intéresse
j'avoue que je me suis j'aime pas encore
en jeu soit question
ça c'est pas très au courant que j'ai
pas l'occasion regarder la télé en ce
moment je peux pas très très bien suivre
c'était entre kaki la dernière guerre
puis souvient non tapas à l'école s'y
met c'est coûteux retenir pendant ce
temps là à lyon la vie continue comme
d'habitude ou presque il est vrai que la
cour d'assises du rhône n'offrent que
peu de place aux éventuels spectateurs
qui voudraient suivre les débats ceux
qui s'intéressent de près ou de loin au
procès pourront lire les comptes rendus
dans la presse ou bien suivre ceux de la
radio et de la télévision
et j'ajouterais gérard beau fils qu'il y
à quelques 900 journalistes qui sont
restés licra du bas du 6 notamment dans
dans ce studio d'antenne 2 nouveau
centre et ont toutes nos éditions
spéciales et puis aussi que la ville de
lyon n'a pas hésité à faire un peu
j'irai sa promotion avec une mallette
laquelle on trouve une carte pour aller
dans un sauna la carte de lyon et le
lion gourmand c'est peut-être pas de
très bons j'ajouterai aussi peu le fait
que l'on a cherché toute la journée une
sorte de dimension émotionnelle mais mes
rêves crois que j'avais ce procès n'aura
été chargé autant de symboles moi
j'étais frappé d'abord d'abord bien
entendu par là la risée de barbie dans
ce box et finalement l'accomplissement
d'un veut que des milliers et des
milliers de gens ont fait à ceux qui
mouraient à côté d'eux c'est à dire
finalement ramené cet homme et témoigner
devant lui et finalement il est il a un
regard il est comme s'il obéissait à
l'ordre je me demande si c'est ce type
qui a toujours été un homme d'ordre même
si lors de tes pervers finalement il est
arrivé et il suit le procès parce que
c'est la loi parce que c'est l'ordre et
quelque chose qui me qui m'échappe dans
sa dans son comportement c'est un homme
qui va qui apparaît comme vouloir parler
vouloir se battre vouloir répondre même
parfois ils oublient qu'ils eurent par
les allemands il parle en français c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est sa
première la première image qui m'a
vraiment et puis la seconde image c'est
tout de même c'est tout de même ces gens
qui sont là enfin sonné victimes nos
parcelles gils et ses hommes ses femmes
comme madame le sèvre comme madame
lagrange face au burn qui raconte des
choses impensables
avec une dignité avec une simplicité qui
vont certainement d'ailleurs pesé d'un
poids très lourd sur les jurés je veux
pas préjuger ça mais ces gens là vous
raconte des choses et et vont le faire
on le voit on le sent ils vont le faire
avec simplicité dignité
moi ça me va très bien frappé rencontre
madame le sommet mme lagrange de la
manière dont elles répétaient à tous les
journalistes y compris avec à nos
confrères étrangers ce qu'elle avait
vécu et c'était tout à fait
impressionnant bouleversant d'un grave
certains côtés on a on a demandé à deux
nos confrères qui suivent ce procès tout
d'abord à tamara golan qui est de
d'israël vous venez d'israël demain
arrivent et quid de la radio des forces
armées ainsi qu'à une règle iker
d'ailleurs d'être on connaît bien
d'allemagne de la télévision allemand de
venir dire un petit peu comment dans
leur pays on a suivi la préparation de
ce procès barbie alors tellement
rigolade en israël on a surtout vu
l'aspect juif je dirais du procès sinon
je crois que je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous c'est les côtés qu'on
laisse les victimes parlait enfin je
crois que c'était le but de sept
concerts comme chez nos procédés gagne
ou qu'on est surpris de voir combien de
gens bien sûr avec les blessures avec
toutes les difficultés sont toujours
intéressés je crois que ça fait honneur
au monde libre et à la france et c'est
comme ça que nous avons présenté ses
projets dans nos journaux et dans nos
radios et c'est un fait sans cela vient
surtout pour les juives mais aussi pour
la justice de mon livre est actuellement
sujette sur deux pages de tous les
journaux il n'y a pas cette jeune du
manioc la filiale française évidemment
journal sur la même page on fait une
grande partie pour damiano parce que
vous savez bien sûr le témoignage des
chaises longues sont plus terribles
comme dit serge klarsfeld mais ici on a
expédié des gens vivent des bourreaux
des lions a envoyé des gens vivant dans
les trains mais quand ils sont arrivés
ils sont arrivés de l'autre côté où il y
avait de mieux on l'avait mis dans les
chambres à gaz où ils sont jamais sortis
une rigueur on a eu l'impression dans le
spiegel dans disait qu'on ne faisait que
c'était un procès je dirais pour les
français et autres français qui vous
l'allemagne était pas conscient oui
alors là je vois un petit peu le
problème c'est de dire certainement ce
procès un grande résonance en allemagne
mais il ya d'un côté les gens quand vous
les avez aussi en france qui disent on
veut vraiment mer et 44 è mais en
allemagne il ya encore un autre côté
c'est le côté que nous les allemands en
fait nous avons fait beaucoup de procès
depuis des années contre les anciens
nazis il veut même des procès que serge
kubla que tu as fait le temps
suscitée par ce que il lui qui ont fait
attention là il ya encore heinrich von
hagen et licha
mais il ya des gens laval dans le
'spiegel' par exemple vous pouvez dire
ça aussi un petit peu dans
on magasine
qui disent eh bah écoutez vous les
français vous avez eu certainement le
bureau de lyon
barbie qui est en allemand mais on dit
un petit peu que c'est en allemand mais
qu'il avait l'aide des français se dire
par exemple que tu que tour du les gens
comme ça qui ont collaboré et les ja des
allemands qui disent regarder chez vous
la collaboration n'arrive jamais été
vraiment un sujet pour les français il
ya le prix ville stern andré françois
poncet ça ça continue comme ça je trouve
ça très dommage parce que c'est là un
article de maman fabien recherché parce
que les faits sont tout à fait
différents je crois que en allemagne n'a
pas beaucoup discuté de ceux de cet
article merci le dossier le plus
sinistre sans doute paul sept dossiers
d'izieu ain comme concernera
le dossier fondamental c'est le plus
touchant symbolique parce qu'il s'agit
de 40 ans c'est la rafle donc de 51
juifs dont 44 enfants du refuge des yeux
c'est un département de l'ain se lasse
pas celle du 6 avril 1944 c'est cette
histoire que ben est idiot et françois
granier on tentait de reconsulter car
tout ce que l'on a envoyé à auschwitz
unis une femme seule est revenue des 44
enfants pas un seul survivant est le
plus jeune avait 5 ans
izieu proches de liot il se trouve la
colonie des enfants réfugiés de
l'hérault en fait c'est une planque pour
enfants juillet 44 le plus âgé de 16 ans
44 gosse venu d'ailleurs de très loin
pour la plupart apatrides déjà anéanti
par le malheur mais vivant c'est le
jeudi saint il est 9 heures il fait beau
personne n'entend les camions de la
gestapo monter la cote un seul adulte
parmi les huit présentés chap
il saute parfaite fenêtre sur ses talons
il croit percevoir pause barbie c'est
l'impulsion au soleil varie sans nous en
sommes au flop et
d'autres habitants izieu affirme avoir
vu klaus barbie en imperméable et
chapeau appuyé contre se battent en
pierre mais quarantaine et c'est long il
reste ce telex envoyés du siège de la
gestapo lyonnaise le jour même à 20h10
au commandement il fait la part belle
prise le lieutenant klaus barbie rend
compte de sa mission du matin il ajoute
on a pu s'assurer ni de l'argent
comptant et des valeurs diverses la
peste brune a déjà tout enlever aux
enfants du refuge même leurs parents un
exemple les petits bendidi croiser leurs
mères dans le camp il ne se voit pas
mais elle elle saura en reconnaissant
dans la baraque aux vêtements le pull
tricoté à son aîné c'est ce qu'il a dû
souffrir lui avec ses petits frères
c'est lui qui a souffert le plus
il était bon
il sait et bien élevés surtout
de la rafle des enfants d'izieu une
survivante une seule et a fait le bloom
leur monitrice vous la voyez là au
centre de la photo
les à embarquer avec eux au fort montluc
à lyon se sert de faux papiers
moi j'ai donné la carte la fosse germe
appel et marie-louise decosse
le lendemain on nous a plu aux chemins
de fer pour drancy
annonce et aller aux wc alors j'ai
maintenant
à 30 minutes du coeur de paris le camp
d'internement de drancy c'est là où les
nazis en acier juifs et les autres avant
la formation des convois de la mort
allez là non et moi je n'ai pas parmi
eux jeudi je suis les appels blum je ne
suis pas marie decorte je veux aller où
les enfants bon lit tu lis ton après les
enfants on les a mis dans les îles vont
d'une version
inconnue
13 avril 1944 convoi 71 entassés dans
des wagons à bestiaux sens où son vivre
destination la pologne ils ont pleuré
beaucoup
il se tenait bien
nous avons voilà j'ai quelques jours ça
n'a pas et nuit de ce cauchemar l'aiea
n'est jamais tout à fait revenu et ne
témoignera pas à lyon
il y avait décroché comme ça plus haut
que la table avec des espèces de longs
manteaux
ce matin cinq jeux pré pirmin ce qu
rebelles ici je prie coco c'était le
plus petit encore deux enfants moi
j'étais la scène et on avance on avance
j'entends des yeux j'ai vu à l'entrée du
camp sera d'éthyle côte je ne le crois
pas
le conte à
fait
intéressant les kinder quels sont tes
enfants
je dis non je sens comme et pousse au
traitement maintenant
et moi je serai comme ça et de l'autre
côté
alors j'avais plus deux enfants
c'est fini ça c'était des moments où je
ne sais plus vu plus vu mais je n'ai pas
cru
aux enfants on a pris deux enfants
l'idée s'enfoncer gable regardant vos
voisins tendant un regard de son enfant
c'est ça c'est vous savez ce qui garde
en revanche le foehn
ce sera l'un des chefs d'inculpation
sans doute le plus sinistre contre klaus
barbie dont 7 est aujourd'hui donc là la
première audience voilà pour l'édition
spéciale que nous vous retransmission en
direct de lyon pour l'actualité saddam
ou physique
merci claude l'actualité de ce lundi
c'est encore la découverte de deux
plantes d'action directe dans la région
de tours ces deux cachette un
appartement et une ferme était utilisé
par deux des quatre dirigeants d'action
directe arrêtés le 21 février dernier
près d'orléans la découverte de ces
nouvelles caches par la police a été
facilitée par la diffusion de
photographies des terroristes dans le
public reportage emmanuel vanier
jean-marie lequertier
georges cipriani et joëlle aubron
habitaient depuis plus d'un an cette
petite maison isolée à une soixantaine
de kilomètres de tours
cipriani et aubron arrêté en février
dernier à vitry aux loges avec rouillan
et ménigon se faisait passer pour des
traducteurs il était très discret et
n'entretenait aucune relation avec leurs
voisins
on se rappelle juste une anecdote
une voiture qui était en panne un jour
de verglas
et
j'ai proposé d'appeler un garagiste il
n'avait pas bonne on va se débrouiller
tout ça selon les enquêteurs c'est
l'analyse des documents saisis à vitry
qui a permis de retrouver hier cette
planque un véritable travail de fourmi
200 gendarmes pour deux mois des
enquêtes dans tout le département
tous les propriétaires ont été
interrogés pour savoir si des locataires
n'avaient pas disparus ou n'avaient pas
payé leur loyer depuis mars c'est le cas
de monsieur madame robin propriétaire de
cette maisonnette ça vous apprendra que
vous n'avez pas vu ça n'avait rien
entendu parler mon mari leur ai écrit on
n'a pas eu de réponse alors là c'est ma
fille qui l'a qui a décidé mon mari
d'aller gendarmerie pour sa part ce
qu'il était devenu on en sait déjà un
accident pensez pas au travail on
pensait qu'ils avaient attrapé un
accident qu'il était mort se trouvent
une chose car elles arrivent tous les
humains comme on les a tous vus tous les
deux bon alors c'est là que mon mari les
a reconnu sur une photo la jeune armée
dans la ferme une arme 20 kilos
d'explosifs les mêmes gars vitry aux
loges des munitions et du matériel pour
en fabriquer une voiture volée et de
nombreux documents c'est la deuxième
planquette action directe localisé dans
la région il y a une semaine les
gendarmes découvraient qu'un studio de
la banlieue de tours avait également
servi de repère aux terroristes d'action
directe
la mort des manuels vitryat le doyen
mondial des greffés du coeur il est
décédé ce matin à marseille à l'âge de
67 ans après avoir vécu pendant 18 ans
avec le coeur d'un autre peerle
emmanuel vitryat c'était le bonheur de
vivre avec un coeur tout neuf un coeur
greffé dans sa poitrine depuis 18 ans à
la place de son propre coeur alors
condamné la transplantation cardiaque
n'en était qu'à ses débuts en 60 ch mais
emmanuel vitryat y croyait encore plus
que cherche urgent bien sa deuxième vie
comme il disait il la partageait entre
la bicyclette
l'association des donneurs de sang dont
il assurait activement la présidence et
le football bien sûr comme supporters de
l'équipe de marseille
il représentait la ville surtout la
ténacité la durance et au sourire la
dignité tout ce qu'on peut tout ce qu'on
voudrait avoir marseille
voit que c'est pas parce que j'avais un
vainqueur et n'était pas à lui et il y a
n'était plus vitryat vitryat contraire
c'est un peu transcendé une fête que il
a trouvé une nouvelle raison de vivre on
peut la trouver que la vie c'était vous
ça valait le coup de tel aviv et à vivre
le plus longtemps possible ce n'est pas
possible emmanuel vitryat était vraiment
un pionnier car le grand succès de la
transplantation cardiaque a commencé
seulement en 80 avec la découverte d'un
médicament anti rejet la cyclosporine
depuis on compte plus de 4000 greffe
cardiaque dans le monde 4000 successeur
pour emmanuel vitryat le doyen des
greffés du coeur le président françois
mitterrand a passé cette journée à
berlin ouest pour participer aux
cérémonies marquant le 750e anniversaire
de la ville le chef de l'état en
présence du chancelier kohl a prononcé
un discours e plaidoyer en faveur d'un
désarmement équilibré il s'est aussi
prononcé pour un dialogue entre les
grandes puissances à berlin pour un
thème de philippe rochot
deux gestes pour marquer le
rapprochement entre la france et
l'allemagne la visite de françois
mitterrand ou plus vieux collège
français de l'étranger avec à ses côtés
le président vice et caire et le
chancelier kohl et puis la restitution
par la france à la ville de berlin des
bas-reliefs de la colonne de la victoire
qui évoquait des conquêtes prussienne et
qui avait été embarqué par les alliés en
45 pour le chef de l'état berlin doit
servir au rapprochement entre les
peuples mais dans cette ville partagée
tribune idéale pour parler des rapports
est ouest on attendait surtout une prise
de position sur le désarmement
tout désarmement
doit être équilibré
et qu'à partir de là les experts
les responsables désignés à cet essai is
examiner sérieusement de quelle façon
réaliser
un nouvel équilibre des fautes
sur la base de désarmement dont je
n'exclus aucune forme
dès lors que l' équilibre président à
cette option
les britanniques éliront leurs députés
le 11 juin prochain c'est à dire un an
avant l'échéance normale décision de
margaret thatcher dont le parti
conservateur bénéficie de la faveur des
sondages madame thatcher espère ainsi
pouvoir remplir un troisième mandat en
france les parlementaires socialistes
saisisse le conseil constitutionnel sur
le projet organisant un référendum en
nouvelle calédonie les élus socialistes
contestent le statut qui sera proposé
aux électeurs calédonien actualité
sociale 3000 emplois supprimés dans les
industries public d'armement terrestre
dans les trois ans à venir la délégation
générale pour l'armement précise qu'elle
n'aura pas recours à des mesures de
licenciement
le nom de l'automobile reprend des
couleurs peugeot et sa qui regroupe les
sociétés peugeot et citroën annonce un
bénéfice net de plus de trois milliards
et demi de francs en 1986 c'est à dire
cette fois plus que l'année précédente
geneviève moll
205 bx ax ce sont les chevaux qui font
caracolé en tête des exportateurs
européens de voitures le groupe psa
peugeot talbot citroën en effet exportée
plus de cinquante deux pour cent de ces
automobiles en 86 mais ce n'est pas
seulement à cause de cela que le groupe
a dégagé autant de bénéfices il a réussi
son redressement parce qu'il a su
adapter ses gammes à la demande et aux
goûts du public il a aussi fait un
énorme effort de productivité en
rebaptisant certains ateliers comme sud
aulnay pour lui ou de poissy pour la 309
des investissements aussi d'érable avec
le revers de la médaille trente cinq
mille suppressions d'emplois en cinq ans
pour cent si ces efforts seraient
aujourd'hui positif jacques élevés ne
fait pas de triomphalisme
nous n'avons pas réussi à couvrir la
totalité nos investissements dans notre
phase de financement c'est à dire la
richesse se crée ton à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise
et puis nous avons de très grandes
ambitions pour l'avenir puisque nous
voulons le lien dans quatre ou cinq ans
le premier constructeur européen et que
cela signifie énormément
d'investissement un milliard et demi de
plus depuis trois ans chaque année et
beaucoup d'efforts de nos zones d'étude
de recherche etc
ces efforts portent à nouveau leurs
fruits puisque pour le premier trimestre
87 psa a gagné une place sur 86 il est
aujourd'hui le troisième constructeur
européen derrière volkswagen et fiat
la météo pour demain mardi brigitte il
faut sortir son parapluie mais
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce que
nous manquions dos c'est vrai qu'il n'a
pas plu depuis longtemps en tout cas de
manière importante à lentement ce ne
sera peut-être pas suffisant mais ce
sera déjà ça une perturbation passé je
vous propose de regarder sur notre carte
powell se situera en fait la pluie
tombera de l'aquitaine jusqu'au pays de
la loire le mastiff sur le nord du
massif central le centre le bassin
parisien et à la bourgogne franche comté
l'alsace là les arts tél et jusqu'à la
picardie donc cela donnera évidemment
des nuages une pluie fine et continue à
l'arrière de cette perturbation sur le
nord-ouest sur les côtes de la manche et
le nord-pas-de-calais ce sera une
succession de nuages et d'éclaircies et
d'averses et puis à l'avant d'abord un
ciel très nuageux du midi pyrénéens
jusqu'aux alpes mais qui ne donnons pas
la ligne e s devront pas de
précipitations seront entrecoupées de
petites éclaircies et de belles
éclaircies sur le pourtour méditerranéen
me due au mistral mistral qui soufflera
fort et les températures c'est l'autre
ses caractéristiques et bien les
températures alpin quelques rares
relativement frais demain nous irons en
milieu d'après midi de 12 à 15 degrés
sur la moitié nord pas plus et sur la
moitié sud de 15 degrés jusqu'à 20 mai
20 degrés seulement sur la corse au
lendemain ce sera le mardi 12 mai le
soleil se lèvera 6h16 couchera 21h19 et
ce sera là s'attacher les cela nous
donnera deux minutes de ferrer en plus
j'ai noté on prend le parapluie et le
club ait bouya ce témoin voilà je vous
retrouve pour le dernier journal vers
23h15 demain télématin à partir de 6h45
invités de paul nahon pour les 4 vérités
sera jacques chaban delmas à propos du
procès barbie à toutes et à tous une
très bonne soirée
e